c'est un rendez vous très attendu qu'il
se prépare place du port villiers près
de la statue de nicéphore niépce
personnages emblématiques de la ville
l'ambiance festive de chalon en mode
guinguette sera bientôt de retour
chaque soir tout l'été l'événement
attire un flux continu de 800 à 1000
personnes
l'idée c'était de retrouver la
guinguette de bords de marne mais là on
a fait en bord de saône donc voilà
pourquoi le nom d'un gay s'est imposé à
nouveau toute une installation à mettre
en place pour accueillir des publics
avec cette année des mesures sanitaires
à faire respecter 10 personnes et pas
plus par groupes sur les gradins et un
peu plus de travail pour les
organisateurs c'est surtout au niveau
des marquages sur le terrain de marque
et les files d'attentes devant les
restaurants les entrées effectivement
aux six ou sept fois on n'a qu'une
entrée et une sortie pour pouvoir avoir
une jauge précise du public 600
personnes au maximum cette année un
tiers de table en moins autour des
chalets de restauration masque
obligatoire pour se déplacer avec
l'espoir malgré tout de maintenir la
convivialité
ça reste un événement majeur festif il
faut que nous de toute façon tampon
final on le traite en tant que tel on
essayant de respecter au maximum les
mesures sanitaires et spécifique à notre
profession est spécifique à la période
on sait pas comment ça va se passer en
terme de fréquentation avec les clients
on sait pas si les gens vont répondre
présents pas présents dans quelle
proportion dans quelle mesure on verra
bien nous techniquement on s'adapte
chalon en mode guinguette ça commence ce
soir avec un pique nique bleu blanc
rouge et des concerts gratuits chaque
soir jusqu'au 26 juillet puis du 15 au
30 août